oh I'm great I mean I'm better than that
Noah Sandton a oh he's got a broken leg
that he does that he does but you know
he still looks great so I'm at the
Charlie's Angels premiere the other
night he's like a bionic man have you
sent him any well wishes I did I like I
texted him while like right after he got
out of surgery and he seemed great so
yeah so a word season is just beginning
how do you feel being here tonight how
do you power through it all this is
awesome I power through it knowing that
at the very end I can take off my heels
and that's fine but this is awesome like
I love to see like my like idols and
everything here so anybody who you're
like I hope I meet this person
um Sandra Oh but I don't know if she was
gonna come but that would be great he's
manifested why Sandra she's my icon like
I think she paved the way for girls who
look like me and it's just like
everything she's everything to me and I
think she's wonderful so yeah so are you
you're are you filming for anything
right now weird you have a bit of a
break right I have a break I just shot
to all the boys two and three back to
back so I'm on a break and I'm breathing
and like just living my life which is
awesome so yeah I was gonna ask I don't
know if you guys shot the third one
already so luckily Noah's leg break
happened after all yes what can we
expect them from two and three so from
two which is out on February 12th on
Netflix worldwide we can expect a love
triangle which is awesome so it's gonna
shake it up I know everyone loves Peter
Kavinsky I know of we're gonna shake it
up see what's up and then in the third
movie we go to three different locations
and shoot we shot all over the world so
it was will be really fun I know that
Jordan Fisher's coming he's coming dunno
he but he's in the movie oh yes he's
amazing he is a disruptive force and
really will stress people out because
he's so good
mm-hmm people gonna fall in love with
someone other than Peter convinced 100%
yeah what happens in three I can't tell
you
she fall in love with herself and I just
did I just crush it did you did support
relationship that you have is the one
you have with yourself
amen anything you're gonna do with the
time off I am going to Vietnam with the
Obamas in December I'm sorry what so
much yes I am gonna drop that real cash
yeah I have a scholarship with Asia
Foundation where I put Vietnamese girls
through a four year education and mrs.
Obama she has the girls Alliance so
we've kind of her together and we're
gonna go see the girls that are pursuing
their education which is amazing in
Vietnam which is my birthplace but I was
adopted up four months old so will be my
first time back so I'll be great yeah
we're gonna get to see any of that on
Netflix I crushed it again
[Music]